it's a game attributed to John Conway a
mathematician at Princeton and it is
called Conway checkers Conway checkers
is a game which is played on an infinite
board so it's infinite in all directions
you take a line and you put it somewhere
in the middle of your board and you're
not going to move it and then what you
do is you take a few checkers and you
place them underneath the line anywhere
you like it's totally random it's up to
you what you want to do and then you
start playing by simplified checkers
there is only one type of move you can
jump over an adjacent checker and then
disappear that checker so I can jump
vertically or I can jump horizontally
and I can do this left right up or down
so there are four possible moves but
they're all of the same type now what is
not allowed is if you have three
checkers in a row you try to jump like
this and you land on something also you
cannot jump over several checkers that's
not allowed
you cannot jump diagonally you limit it
to jumping only horizontally left and
right or vertically up and down in of
course at some point you may jump over
the line because you will be close to it
there you go
this is yeah that's a lot in fact your
goal is to get as high as possible on
the line so Conway's challenge to us is
if you start below the line in whatever
configuration you wish as many checkers
you wish and you follow those simple
rules what is the highest row above the
line that you can reach well what do you
think I think the answer is going to be
disappointingly low but is that what
your gut feeling says or your experience
well part of me thinks if I can use an
infinite number of checkers in any
configuration I want I should be able to
build some mechanism to push quite high
but that's right that's what my gut
feeling said about the problem I said
what kind of question is this of course
I will somehow create an algorithm
perhaps inductive algorithm and reach
higher and higher and higher ropes
exactly so let's try and let us be
fishing do I really need the whole army
of checkers to reach the first row well
obviously if I put the checkers like
this I'm not gonna go anywhere above the
line but if I put them vertically
everyone can play this quite easily you
can jump over and you know you reach to
Row 1 all right let's try Row 2 now at
this point the audience should stop the
video and really try it because it's not
entirely obvious what to do
I think we need to put if we put another
two there we can feed it so Brady has
learned a lot of mathematics and his
intuition is really good indeed if we
start like this let's see one move two
moves and finally three moves and we are
in row two above the line so we're done
now for an extra challenge row three
how many checkers do you think we will
need yes but the question is in what
configuration maybe you can use the
smaller ones better yeah okay he's so
good you've seen this before
my goodness you're my fastest to them
how's that
Brady your arms let's try you think you
can play it or oh yeah yeah okay okay
try so what we did before
yes and then and then that they're not
there okay that's gone and then we need
to get that to there okay
ah this looks very promising do you know
what so let's think we use two four and
eight checkers to get to row one two and
three this looks very determined process
to me how many checkers shall we try for
all four six times
I do but you know what there isn't an
configuration with 16 even
more the pattern breaks I can show you
the configuration that actually wins and
there it is so that's 20 checkers and
the viewers can try to play with those
checkers and see if you can reach the
fourth row this is actually quite a feat
[Music]
I'm not going to try to try it on Braden
this is really tough you start with
those 20 checkers you play play play
play and you get to Row 4 in fact there
are other configurations with slightly
more checkers for example 21 and so the
way you do it is you arrange them on 4
by 5 so we're going to have already 20
checkers which is what we had before but
in this particular situation you put one
more so you end up with 21 checkers and
it's kind of a very nice symmetric
situation that actually capitalizes on
our previous attempt to reach Row 3 so
you can try this and indeed reach
somewhere up row 4 of course with 21
points this game here is less efficient
than the previous one which was with 20
and you can ask yourself is there a more
efficient game with 1918 and so on but
really that's not the point of the game
and now the challenge zone so we have 21
here well how many do you think we need
for all 5 we went more than twice up
from the previous case so if we go more
than twice up maybe about 50 yeah 50 or
60 I think it's gonna become impossible
I'm already surprised we got to 4 I
think it's gonna become impossible as I
but I don't see any restriction what can
possibly stop us from reaching the fifth
row so there is this mysterious into
he called a mana variant a feature that
moves only in one direction it either
only increases or only decreases and
that feature prevents us somehow from
reaching the FIFRA
but getting that feature extrapolating
it from this game is actually quite
complex so let's get to work are you
ready to get to work
if so the proof video showing that you
cannot reach row 5 is on our second
channel numberphile 2 which is where I
put longer more detailed videos this is
quite a long proof but it's really
interesting easy to follow and it
involves the golden ratio loads I'll
also include some links on the screen
underneath to other videos that may be
of interest including our interviews
with John Conway himself
you